i've asked uh nigel bulman to have a
look at this whole issue of
uh supply chain finance and
uh and given him you know pretty much
carte blanche to
uh ask anybody whatever he needs to to
find out
to to you know i would like it to be
done quickly
but i want him to have the maximum
possible access and uh so we can all
understand
exactly what's happened and uh and and
that will of course be presented to
parliament in due course
you say cut blush and maximum possible
access some of your critics are asking
why you're not
committing to a full independent inquiry
well i've got every confidence in in
nigel bourbon i think he'll do an
outstanding job he's done a very good
job on
uh on on pp that i've been but i've been
reading
and i think that we we need to
understand exactly what's been going on
uh with this supply chain finance
question
and uh he you know he's got uh we'll
make sure
everybody uh gives him their time and he
can
set out his thoughts and and set out his
uh his arguments
what do you make of mr cameron's
behavior well that's a matter for for
nigel portman
finally prime minister those who know
the history of you and your former boss
might be
uh raising an eyebrow and thinking
you're trying to rough up a rival is
that what's happening here
i think people have just got uh
questions that they need to
satisfy themselves by including me about
how this uh supply chain finance stuff
uh is meant to
to work i mean i i don't think that it's
going on at
present anywhere in government but i
need to we need to understand
exactly what the intention was how it
came about and that's what nigel
boardman is going to do
thank